[MUSIC]
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
TO "TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
NOT LONG AFTER JACK RUBY SHOT
LEAVE HARVEY OSWALD ON CAMERA IN
THE BASEMENT OF POLICE
HEADQUARTERS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE KENTY -- KENNEDY
ASSASSINATION.
THAT LONE GUNMAN IS MURDERED BY
ANOTHER LONE MAN.
LIGHTNING, RARE BUT POSSIBLE.
IF ALL OF YOUR FAMILY IS STRUCK
BY LIGHTNING YOU MIGHT SUSPECT
THESE ARE NOT NATURAL EVENTS.
THEY ARE.
THIS BIZARRE CHAIN OF KILLINGS
NATURAL.
AFTER THE JFK ASSASSINATION
JOHNSON WHITE HOUSE RELEASED
WARREN REPORT.
MOTIVES REMAINED UNCLEAR.
BOTH LEE OSWALD AND JACK RUBY
ACTED ALONE.
CASE CLOSED.
TIME TO MOVE ON.
MANY AMERICANS DID MUF ON.
AT THE TIME THEY HAD NO IDEA HOW
SHOTTY AND CORRUPT.
WITH HELD INFORMATION FROM
INVESTIGATORS.
EVEN THEN AT THE TIME BEFORE
THAT WAS KNOWN GOVERNMENT'S
EXPLANATION DIDN'T SEEM ENTIRELY
PLAUSIBLE.
SOME PEOPLE STARTED ASKING
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS.
IT WAS AT THAT POINT AMERICANS
STARTED TO DOUBT THE OFFICIAL
STORY TERM CONSPIRACY ENTERED
OUR LEXACON.
CONSPIRACY THEORY DIDN'T EXIST
BEFORE 1964.
YEAR WARREN COMMISSION ISSUED
REPORT, "NEW YORK TIMES"
PUBLISHED FIVE STORIES IN WHICH
CONSPIRACY APPEARED.
APPEARS IN EVERY STORY ABOUT
AMERICAN POLITICS.
IT IS WIELDED AS A WEAPON
AGAINST ANYONE THAT ASKS
QUESTIONS GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE ANSWERING.
DESPITE 60 YEARS OF NAME
CALLING.
APRIL 1964 PSYCHIATRIST LOUIS
JOYLYNN WEST VISITED JACK RUBE
WI.
ACCORDING TO WEST, HE FOUND JACK
RUBY WAS TECHNICALLY INSANE AND
IN NEED OF IMMEDIATE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATION.
RUBY HAD SEEN PERFECTLY INSANE.
WEST PRONOUNCED HIM CRAZY.
WHAT WEST DID NOT SAY WAS THAT
HE WAS WORKING FOR THE C.I.A. AT
THE TIME.
WEST WAS A CONTRACT PSYCHIATRIST
FOR THE SPY AGENCY AND EXPERT ON
MIND CONTROL AND PROMPT
T
PROMINENT PLAYER.
ALL THE PSYCHIATRISTS IN THE
WORLD.
WHAT IN THE WORLD WAS THIS GUY
DOING IN JACK RUBY'S PRISON
CELL?
MEDIA DIDN'T SEEM INTERESTED IN
FINDING OUT.
"NEW YORK TIMES" OBITUARY OF
WEST NEVER MENTIONED HE WORKED
FOR C.I.A. OR MUCH LESS IN JACK
RUBY'S CELL.
1976 LONG FORGOTTEN, HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES A SPECIAL
COMMITTEE TO REINVEST THE
ASSASSINATION.
JACK KENNEDY WAS MURDERED AS A
RESULT OF A CONSPIRACY.
QUESTION IS CONSPIRACY BY WHOM?
OBVIOUS SUSPECT C.I.A.
WHY ELSE WOULD AGENCY HOLD
CRITICAL EVIDENCE FOR
INVESTIGATORS BENIGN EXPLANATION
MAINTAINING THIS LEVEL OF
INDUSTR
SECRECY.
1992 CONGRESS PASSED PRESIDENT
JFK PRESIDENT RECORDS ACT.
ALL DOCUMENTS BY 2017, 54 YEARS
AFTER JFK KILLED.
UNDER INTENSE PRESSURE FROM MIKE
POMPEO WITH HELD THOUSANDS OF
C.I.A. DOCUMENTS.
TODAY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DID EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
AFTER NEARLY 60 YEARS.
AFTER THE DEATH OF EVERY SINGLE
PERSON INVOLVED.
BUT WE STILL CAN'T SEE THEM.
CLEARLY NOT TO PROTECT ANY
PERSON THEY ARE ALL DEAD.
IT IS TO PROTECT AN INSTITUTION.
BUT WHY?
TODAY WE DECIDED TO FIND OUT.
WE SPOKE TO SOMEONE WHO HAD
ACCESS TO THE DOCUMENTS.
PERSON DEEPLY FAMILIAR WITH WHAT
THEY CONTAIN.
DID THE C.I.A. HAVE A HAND IN
MURDER OF JFK.
QUOTE, ANSWER IS YES.
I BELIEVE THEY WERE INVOLVED.
IT IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
IT IS ALL FAKE.
HARD TO IMAGINE MORE JARRING
RESPONSE THEN THAT.
THIS IS NOT A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST WE SPOKE TO.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THIS IS SOMEONE WITH DIRECTED
KNOWLEDGE OF INFORMATION ONCE
AGAIN WITH HELD FROM THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, ANSWER WE
RECEIVED UNEQUIVOCAL YES.
C.I.A. INVOLVED IN ASSASSINATION
OF PRESIDENT.
SOME WILL NOT BE SURPRISED TO
HEAR THAT.
THEY SUSPECTED IT ALL ALONG.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU THOUGHT.
PAUSE TO CONSIDER WHAT THIS
MEANS IN U.S. GOVERNMENT FORCES
MORE POWERFUL THAN ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT OVERSEE THEM.
THEY CAN EFFECT ELECTION
OUTCOMES AND HIDE COMPLICITY OF
MURDER OF AMERICAN PRESIDENT AND
DO ANYTHING THEY WANT.
THEY CONSTITUTE GOVERNMENT
WITHIN A GOVERNMENT MOCKING BY
VERY EXISTENCE IDEA OF
DEMOCRACY.
AS CYNICAL AS WE HAVE BECOME, WE
WERE SHOCKED TO LEARN THIS.
IT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AMERICANS HAVE TRUSTED
GOVERNMENT LESS WITH EVERY
PASSING YEAR SINCE KILLING OF
JOHN F. KENNEDY.
PEOPLE HAVE KNOWN THIS A LONG
TIME.
PEOPLE WOULD INCLUDE EVERY
DIRECTOR OF C.I.A. SINCE 1963
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE OBAMA'S
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN.
ALSO WE ARE SAD TO SAY OUR
FRIEND MIKE POMPEO WHO RAN
C.I.A. LAST ADMINISTRATION.
MIKE POMPEO KNEW THI